can you give me a third reason third
reason let me give you all the clue
right because these reasons are okay
buddy you can all improve a lot because
think about what we've looked at already
under she's not that much right we had a
we could say a structure continuum
structured instruction no one's
mentioned anything to do that yet okay
do you guys want to give me a reason
okay
explained okay can someone else on the
team explain what she's talking about
because I'm not convinced all of you
understand what's going on asiak can you
explain what's your change reason no
Denikin screen you explain
I don't you read explanation I want your
explanation
okay all right okay ah that I'll pay
that okay okay so it was um it's um how
do we say this it's a bit of an
interpretation problem right it's an
inability to interpret it or to see
through yeah okay all right I'll pay
that that's true
computers do this is actually a really
problem this is actually a language
problem
okay so natural language is very
difficult for computers to deal with and
issues of tone and sarcasm all those
kind of things computers don't pick them
up for wrong okay good
you're up to three Oh back to this okay
so okay so then poses to everyone is
this a good thing or a bad thing it
depends on the situation good I would
say sometimes this is much like with
this situation here where the perceives
how are sometimes this is good sometimes
this is good sometimes it's bad right
okay